hi my name is markiplier and look at
this
this is our new cloak slips it's our
extremely comfortable slipper that we
made ourselves available in four colors
we really didn't make it i believe the
prompt to ideating this thing was a
sleeping bag for your foot and so we
made just that
a sleeping bag for your foot i actually
unironically have not taken this off
since i got it it's very nice so check
it out link in the description
thank you
have a good day look at this
son of a [ __ ]
zoom zoom more zoom
more
zoom more
more more zoom more
there
more
wow this is the man from the window the
premise of this game is that there is a
man in your window and he will be inside
soon and there's nothing that you can do
about it
literally through the duration of this
game there is a man trying to get into
your house
to this game because he's going to teach
you how to do this start a new game
press x now to skip interest i've never
played
it oh
hi
[Music]
what in the
what
what
in
the goddamn hell
is this
i'm sorry hold on
what
there was nothing
nothing about me looking at this and
downloading it that would indicate
that a rabbit with the
biggest boobs i've ever seen on anything
ever would walk and flop a pizza down on
the table
i sat on the couch there was nothing
no one anyway oh my stars i am tired
what a long day
seems like i keep getting home later in
late is this me am i playing mama rabbit
but that's just how it is sometimes i
ain't giving up
i'd better try to get some sleep gunny
need to be up early bright and early to
cook breakfast for the little one
oh
mama mama
junior what on earth are you doing up
this late you know you have school
tomorrow but mama the man from the book
is gonna get me
huh what man what book the man in my
story book see
oh
i get it
the man from the window give it here
you got a convenient shelf to read that
on the man from the window is quite the
odd fellow with his big beady eyes and
sunken nose why he just wants to say
hello
as he smiles from ear to ear the man
wanders the quiet night through alleys
and backyards he goes making very sure
to stay out of sight he silently peers
through windows searching for one thing
and one thing only a new friend is all
he wants for the man is very very lonely
once you hear his tap tap tapping at the
window you'll know he's found a new
friend to play for now you have only
five minutes before before he takes you
away
but do not fret for staying in one place
is the man's only peeve keep him at bay
for another five minutes and he'll
leave
the man is in his element doing what he
does best next he will look under the
place where you often rest
the man will more walk than he will
lurch the place under the mirror is
where he will search
the man has no useful trinket or token
he will now check under the place where
bread is broken
the man indeed is very very bold soon he
will check inside the place which is
cold
the man has no friends no family no son
and no daughter
next he will check the place which holds
water
junior this is just one of those scary
books people write
you're too young to be reading this kind
of stuff it'll scare your little mind
after death but mama i saw him outside i
really did
it's just a book sweetie it ain't real
now get that cottontail off to bed right
now at this rate you won't want to wake
up in the huh
what am i seeing
why do i i see something out there
but it doesn't look quite like the face
of the the man in the window it's him
he's out there calm calm down junior
whatever's out there i'm pretty sure it
ain't a monster
junior yes
where'd you get this book from it was on
the table when i got home from school
you got it for me right oh dear lord
this ain't good
okay
am i am i i am mama
junior
huh junior
follow me
okay am i about to die you said i have
five minutes
should we leave
oh
my god
oh my god okay
i better take my keys with me picked up
keys
i'd better take some donuts
eat the donuts
okay um
so junior
junior could easily get under there and
hide
don't hide him there i think i remember
something about going on her table and
then inwards cold
don't hide him there the microwave
junior
all right fine
if i were to uh be relatively not stupid
about this
i see something outside
cabinet sync is big enough for junior to
hide
don't hide him there
just very curious as what's gonna happen
oh well that's inconvenient
oh no wait no that's fine
man i'm slow
i'm a little sluggish you know
oh
no
oh
no
[Applause]
oh no
god why
am i immature am i am i just immature is
that what is that what this is amounting
to
oh my
god
holy [ __ ] okay well that's a problem um
let me take another peek there
peekaboo
ah this is fine
this is fine um did i lock the door i
don't know
okay still just looking there okay
hey
how you doing well listen uh i'm gonna
kick the [ __ ] out of you if you open
that door i'm gonna just
i'm gonna chest bump you and you're
gonna be sent into orbit don't even try
it you [ __ ] don't even try it
i'm gonna crush you in between my
massive mams are you prepared for this i
don't think you are i don't think you
are
yeah maybe if you blink some of your
eyes wouldn't be so bloodshot nerd you
think you could handle this no now you
can't handle this no you can't milk me
you'll never milk me i have no idea how
long it's been
still there are you waiting for me to do
something or or is this really just a
running out of the clock kind of thing
oh
it was exactly 2 a.m when the man
approached the front door
the door was left unlocked and unbarred
so he walked straight in i didn't know
if it was an option to do anything about
that
oh hey
yeah one of it what are you gonna do
the man had found his new friend
he has to be nearby still in a way
they've got this far this quick i'll go
find him myself if i have to
in line the man broke in and just took
him i couldn't stop him please someone
just find him please how did he get by
me i was right there i was right on top
of the play he literally couldn't see
him around me
all right okay i know where to hide him
i think under unless there's like a
different story each time but i think
under the sink would be the logical
place right that would be the logical
place
okay junior could fit in there all right
come here junior
follow me
oh what if i like open the box is that
gonna help
open the box you want some donuts buddy
should i take the keys i'll leave him no
i'll take him
i got keys
hey uh junior
god get out of the way junior
uh junior
hop on in you you do that wait what
about is there there's no other place
no no no i think that where the water is
held would be the wash tub
okay get under there hide under the sink
don't come out until i say so
don't be we'll be all right i think
maybe
stay put
i could probably hide here don't hide
here
wait am i supposed to hide too
i didn't know i was supposed to hide
oh my god
okay so it's not letting me lock it so
i'm assuming that's not really the idea
push in front of the door
it'll take about
oh
perfect
oh interesting okay well that's helpful
oh
yeah again it's not really letting me
lock it
i sure ain't fitting in there yeah i
i see that
and i don't think i'm
not gonna be able to hide under there
what what happens if i hide in the wash
tub i don't think oh my god i'm too
girthy for that i don't think that's
gonna do anything
wait hang on like i think i better close
the door first
don't worry i'm gonna take a bath he'll
never find me it's exactly at 2am when
the man appears the door the door was
left unlocked but then man was unable to
open it a large and heavy couch had been
pushed in front of the door took the man
an entire minute to break through the
barricaded door
the time was now 201 am
the man spotted a box of donuts sitting
on the table
the man took an entire minute to eat
them all
perfect it was 202.
perfect
perfect
hey hold on the man looked under this
wait i didn't hold on
hold on wait maybe i read the story
wrong hold on wait a minute wait a
minute just me in the tub oh no
better not find me
i get it now the red and blue that's
supposed to be like police sirens
oh my god
okay so there's got to be a way to lock
the door right that has to be a thing
because if it wasn't a thing then why
would it be a thing right so there's a
way to lock the door that would buy me
another minute the donuts is another
minute um
let's see turn pages left click lock
holding key i have an inventory ah tab
to cycle the ah
okay got it okay just stay right there
junior don't worry about a thing i got
this junior don't worry about it i don't
remember why you he went straight for
under the sink
as a little strange no not that not that
hold the horse
oh god
okay
next he will ch check the place that
holds water
oh water
cold
mirror so bed no oh rest okay so i need
to put him in the rest place okay
here we go let's lock the door
did i lock it
i'm assuming that's locked i don't know
whatever
open the box
follow me child
under here
hi
hi junior
and then i'm gonna go in the tub
don't worry
this is fine
oh damn it i got this junior don't worry
i'm hiding
okay here we go
door had been locked there we go 30
seconds a large thing okay that was not
too many it was a minute and a half
okay
to a one ish
to one one and a half
it's delicious donuts great
okay entire minute
202
stomp stomp stomp uh
well this is awkward
that's fine don't worry about me
oh wait no hold on wait oh hold on oh
where me me
ah
uh-oh
mama
that's coffee come out
oh boy
oh that's sad
well that's very sad
um i am now dead or
something but hey at least i still have
my personality and my
incredible rack uh okay i'm just gonna
look at the last ones so br table and
water okay got it okay that's perfect
all right so i'm gonna grab this open
this it takes a minute to open this
probably i don't know okay and then um
like this okay that's locked i'm sure of
it 100
okay so it was table and wash tub i'm
gonna put junior under the table okay
junior you're coming with me
follow me actually you know i guess it
doesn't really matter
considering okay so you're there
just get in the tub don't worry
it's fine probably
don't worry about it don't worry about
it don't worry about it i'm going under
the table
me first i am priority after all perfect
okay yes
don't mind me
you can't see me you can't see me
delicious
okay now i've got this
easy peasy
wow
don't
yes yes easy
looked under the sink
nothing idiot
wasting time
like a fool
203
under the bed a nice try
idiot
found nothing
stupid
[Music]
oh man this guy is dumb and bad
oh i wonder if i can like turn on the tv
or something would that distract him i
have no idea i don't think time is
passing nearly fast enough i think i may
have still there might still be an
element that is missing here because um
oh [ __ ] no oh dude oh junior uh junior
oh no junior um oh ah
ah junior please uh
frick god i've got too much blood in not
the brain part of my body i'm i'm not
talking that i have a bone or i'm
talking like my massive memories just
require too much blood
none of it can get up to my head even my
analogies fall flat on their face
much like my attempts to rescue my child
trying again
okay there must be something i i must be
able to like turn on the tv i bet that's
the thing or some other distraction can
i please
junior do you know anything else of what
to do there has to be something right
no way i'm fitting there
see that
tap
i mean there's clearly this which open
the box
take the keys that's clear that's
obvious there's no lights or anything
like that
microwave's not a thing really is there
nothing
else that i can do
i feel like i might be dumb oh frick uh
hold on that's not gonna work obviously
so there's gotta be something else that
i'm missing
[Music]
oh
right
of course okay i got it i got it this
time i have it junior don't worry it's
gonna be fine okay move couch in front
wham what i do is i take the keys open
the box of the donuts i take the keys i
be sure to i locked it apparently i i
think i did so what's gonna happen is
junior gonna come with me follow me
take my hand
and you're gonna go in here they're both
in here is the last place so hi junior
there
you're scared yeah whatever shut up kid
get under the sink when you stop
complaining for a moment then just do as
you're told okay so what's gonna happen
i lock that door
and then i close this and then i lock it
and then i hop in the tub
rub-a-dub-dub
i didn't realize i could lock the other
doors
hehe
there we go now we're in business
and then eat the donuts
mosey on
it's now technically two minutes and 30
seconds and now
yes yes
there we go now it's two minutes
it's three minutes
so now it's three minutes curl cure cure
kill kill
kill kill
cure
nice
nice nothing
idiot
done done done i win i win i win i win
i win
i win i win
so then bam
nothing
204
looking here it'll be another 30 seconds
and then the door and then boom
nothing
fool
fool
and then one last thing
oh didn't even need it two or five the
man's time was up and he knew it so as
quickly as he arrived the man from the
window left
whoa oh my god he did not arrive that
quickly i will admit
mama is he gone
he's gone don't worry hooray
i knew you could do it
oh no what mama eat all the donuts i
wanted one
oh my goodness child don't scare me like
that i'll bring you some from work
tomorrow okay
okay
and junior huh no more cursed books all
right i ain't up to dealing with that
again
well what are we gonna do about the
woman from the door
the who
just kidding
where am i what am i going to do with
you what am i going to do with you throw
you through the door i had way more fun
with that than i thought i would um
one star
are there more stars to get
what do you mean one star what do you
mean don't do this to me i'm having five
nights at freddy's flashbacks please
please have mercy have
mercy
it's fun i like that a lot it's
obviously like there's some rough edges
to it but weirdly it had like a charm to
it it kind of had like grandma vibes you
know grandma the game not quite as
intricate as that but still it kind of
had those vibes just very simplistic and
also just like god the character model i
of all the things that i expected to
walk through that door bunny mama was
not it by the way that was very fun so
thank you everybody so much for watching
hope you enjoyed the man from the window
i look forward to the woman from the
door it should be a fun interesting time
and and honestly literally i think this
was really good i enjoyed it a lot so
thank you let me know what you thought
down in the comments below check out all
my links down there for various podcasts
of which i am a part of that you will
enjoy very much with bob wade and tyler
and also if you haven't seen in space
with markiplier i recommend checking
that out it's my biggest project yet and
i know you'll love it thank you and as
always i will see you
in the next video bye-bye
thick bunny
[Music]